[Music]
after watching this video you should be
prepared to outline four unique types of
video content in their individual
purposes to explain why increased
smartphone penetration drives the value
of video content to recognize why the
psychological concept of mirroring makes
video an essential component of brand
building and to identify three lengths
of video and explain what each length is
best used for let's begin lesson 3
leveraging video and social content now
in part 2 of this series we talked about
the immense value of images when it
comes to social media marketing and the
content marketing that you're doing on
the web when we look at this from the
video side of things there's a lot of
ways in which video marketing is even
stronger because for all the power
images add your message video lets you
take it a step further provide more
context provide more information even
the span of just a few seconds suddenly
takes that still image and adds more
depth adds more concept adds more ideas
around it so that people can really
receive the message that you're trying
to get in front of them the videos are a
powerful tool in the social marketing
world in fact globally well over half of
marketers claim that video is the type
of content that delivers the strongest
ROI of everything they produce and
that's something that's really important
to keep in mind when we consider the
fact that to a lot of companies video is
a heavier investment than simply
producing text now of course as we'll go
through in this series a lot of the new
forms of video that are popping up and
becoming quite popular can be done for
much more reasonable much lower cost now
videos also help drive conversions
shoppers who view videos about a product
or service are 1.81 times more likely to
make a purchase the non video viewers
and again that's really important when
we look at the conversion potential and
leading people into and through that
sales funnel that we've created now it's
also important to understand that
smartphones have played a huge role in
the growth of video as
quality improves affordability comes
online globally as access all over the
world is amping up in fact in a lot of
developing countries more people have
internet access via a handheld device
than they do a desktop computer so as
these things are happening both creation
and consumption of photos and videos
have gone up and continues to go up
in fact video growth is not slowing down
anytime soon up to 72 percent of all
Internet traffic in 2017 is expected to
be the viewing of videos between mobile
usage and specifically second screen
viewing video is going to continue to
grow now there's a lot of value in video
marketing both on the b2c side and on
the b2b side and that's an important
thing to remember in a world where a lot
of times the b2b enterprise side
sometimes struggle to embrace a lot of
the same opportunities that show up for
the b2c marketplace now with more
information available now and less time
executives are finding that video is a
way to quickly understand complex ideas
and offerings in fact 59% of Forbes
surveyed executives so they would rather
watch a video than read an article so
again it's something to keep in mind as
people are coming into your sales funnel
how to help continue pushing them
through that now when we look at the
psychology of video much like we talked
about the psychology of images and how
our brain processes things differently
it's important to remember that there's
a lot of science at play here when we
watch videos our minds relax and our
cognitive functions actually create an
empathetic connection to what we're
seeing on the screen in other words we
are able to relate more fully and more
completely to what we're viewing we tend
to experience the emotions and the ideas
and the excitement that we see happening
in the video this is a concept that's
called mirroring now to a degree
whatever it is that we're watching we
tend to experience as if we're part of
it
so what we watch and what we feel it's
what's demonstrated so whether that's
happy or sad or
set or inspired it's why the news
impacts people it's why those emotional
viral videos that come out around the
holiday season make people feel all warm
and fuzzy or why we love pictures of
laughing babies and adorable puppy dogs
mirroring is very important because of
how it allows people to connect and
relate to us but it's also a very
powerful sales tool because it allows us
to help put people in a mindset that we
want them to be in as part of that sales
cycle now when while reading triggers
parts of our brains that help us think
video triggers the parts that help us
feel so again it's important to look at
how the two can work in tandem
especially on that b2b side that text
those articles those white papers those
are important because they help us
process think understand but video helps
take that to the next step and ties an
emotional reaction to it so videos
become a more emotional form of
marketing now when we look at the idea
of making use of video versus say making
use of text it comes down to the types
of visitors or maybe even where people
are in your sales cycle so in terms of
traffic we can break people up into the
idea of goal-oriented visitors and
browsing visitors so the browsing
visitors being sort of our unintentional
types they didn't really come there with
a purpose the type of visitor determines
the desire and the need for video is
part of your process the browser's are
the people who come in because they're
curious they're open to new information
but they don't necessarily have a
specific goal they may not even be in
your sales funnel yet other than in the
very early exploratory stages they tend
to pay attention to vibrant visuals and
easily absorb video content now on the
other hand the goal-oriented users that
come into your site come with a specific
need and they are process oriented to
meet it a step-by-step easy conversion
funnel flow this is where usability is
very important these users are more
likely to choose text over video so when
you think about
different types of content that you've
prepared for different stages of your
buying cycle especially if you're using
a form of email marketing that's
triggering people into the next step in
the next style of content and helping
move them through or if your sales team
is sending out specific forms of
collateral use people move through this
is something you want to keep in mind in
terms of when you might want to leverage
video marketing versus when you might
want to stick with text-based marketing
so consider the fact that the more
rationally oriented the decision is the
more influence texts will have but for
lifestyle and personal choice areas
pretty much anything that's more of an
emotional decision video tends to
perform very well hey once you become an
expert in digital marketing then
subscribe to the simple learn Channel
and click here to watch more such videos
turn up and get certified in digital
marketing click here